for several days now cryptocurrencies
have been in a free fall out of fear
that the second largest crypto exchange
FTX may go bankrupt Sam bankman freed
the company's founder and CEO is
desperately trying to find a Lifeline
for his collapsing exchange he blames
himself for the crash admitting he effed
up and should have done better in a
tweet yesterday Vlad gutier is here to
show us what's going on inside the often
confusing world of cryptocurrency Vlad
what's up man good morning Nate good to
see my brother so let me explain things
really took a turn for FTX after a deal
to sell the exchange to its top rival
went South now bankman freed also faces
his own personal financial troubles as
the CEO who was once valued at 26
billion dollars has lost nearly all of
his wealth in just a matter of days
like I was saying it's FTX it's a safe
and easy way to get into crypto
so FTX is
Super Bowl ad
poon some of Mankind's greatest
inventions I call it the wheel one of
the worst ideas I've ever heard and even
the world's leading cryptocurrency
exchange itself and I'm never wrong
about this stuff never
but the punch line isn't so funny now
that FTX is on the verge of collapse FTX
is the safest and easiest way to buy and
sell crypto it's the best way to get in
the game the company Drew big name
investors like Tom Brady and was worth
enough money to strike a major league
marketing deal and buy into the name of
a major sports arena but now it and all
of crypto including Bitcoin is in crisis
mode FTX CEO Sam bankman freed who
graced the covers of Fortune and Forbes
magazines as one of the world's youngest
billionaires he is now scrambling to
find enough funds to give investors
their money back after another exchange
binance backed out of a planned deal to
rescue FTX all the withdrawals are stuck
I can't get the money out Evan Luther is
an investor who has seen the value of
his crypto Holdings plummet and now
can't even withdraw what's left in his
FTX account I thought it was very very
secure I have lost almost a couple
million dollars I am probably never
going to trust any exchange anymore uh
I'm only going to keep money in my hard
wallet so this was a very very big
lesson for me right before his company
began to collapse bankman free tweeted
FTX is fine assets are fine FTX has
enough to cover all client Holdings
assuring clients their money was Secure
but the Tweet was quickly deleted what
you're witnessing is a classic example
of a run FCX users were worried that
they wouldn't be able to get their funds
out be it cryptocurrency so they all
lined up and FTX didn't have the cash on
hand to pay them out according to the AP
FTX is under investigation by U.S
Regulators over its handling of customer
funds the White House yesterday issuing
this warning but the most recent new
news further underscores these concerns
and highlights why uh prudent regulation
of cryptocurrencies is indeed needed
many still feel cryptocurrencies are
here to stay but with this massive
downturn in value its future is
uncertain really this is an asset with
no inherent value there's no
fundamentals it trades entirely on
sentiment and sentiment is fickle and
right now sentiment is very negative
this also affects a lot of big name
celebrities who have some of their
investments in FTX Tom Brady we
mentioned Gisele Bundchen Steph Curry
and David Big Papi Ortiz just to name a
few these are folks that have their
money in this currency and it's trade-on
sentiment and sentiment is fickle yeah
we show a video of coins there there's
the the coins don't exist except for in
a server right they're they're pieces of
data and that's what you heard Kerry and
Jean-Pierre basically saying you need to
have regulatory uh at least some kind of
regulatory environment to ensure that
investors don't lose their money that's
what you have when you buy a stock a
bond currencies Commodities crypto sign
in place yet at least how about the
comment that he just made at the end an
asset with no inherent values last time
I checked that's not good it's not good
A lot of people bought Lamborghinis on
that value
I know the financial spaces your old
stomping ground so we got to talk during
the commercial let's do it